ICD is the oldest data standard dating directly back to the 1800s and
more indirectly to earlier centuries when researchers
became interested in the causes of human mortality.
One of these was John Gaunt,
who in the mid 1600s,
probably some of the first research on the causes of human mortality.
The history of ICD is quite interesting,
so I posted a link you can read if you desire.
Traditionally, ICD was a list or classification of medical diagnoses,
maintained by the World Health Organization,
WHO, and updated every 10 years.
ICD-10, adopted in 1994,
is the current version,
and work is well underway on ICD-11 for its schedule release in 2018.
The US finally adopted ICD-10 on October 1, 2015.
Well, after most other countries.
The switch was a substantial effort,
because ICD-10 is a major quantitative and qualitative expansion
of ICD-9 as you can see here.
ICD-10 has more than five times as many codes
to represent very specific clinical details.
Note that it can provide laterality,
so in this example for breast cancer,
it can indicate in which lower outer quadrant the disease was located.
In fact, ICD-10 is an ontology,
capable of representing clinical relationships.
For example, as shown here,
we can encode the fact that the patient has gout affecting their left shoulder,
but they have not yet developed a uric acid deposit,
called a tophus, in that shoulder.
ICD -10 codes are required on health care claims.
Potential uses of the added detail in
ICD-10 could include more appropriate provider reimbursement,
and preventing fraud caused by duplicate billing for the same service.
However, as the Applicadia video demonstrates,
the complexity of the coding system is itself a problem for both providers and payers.
You will find ICD-10 codes in FHIR resources.